you have a marinade that includes a most
unusual ingredient that most of us love
when we were younger but probably would
never think to use in a marinade
what is it drew it's fruit beer hello
listen if you can have beer can chicken
why not rip your steak
are you ready to find your inner butcher
babe yes and i just took a sip of the
root beer all right
take me through this teach me the
marinade all right this is so simple
all you need is some soy sauce right in
a bowl delicious
we've got two tablespoons in here got it
and we've got two tablespoons of mustard
you can use any damn kind you like all
mustard's good to me
all right next smoked paprika gotta get
the smoked one because it tastes like
the grill it tastes like summer time
and highlight and how much of this two
tablespoons
to your health apple cider vinegar i
love apple cider vinegar it really gives
a bright acidity and it's
really going to aid in the marination
for this recipe and actually
i call them recipes because this recipe
can bless your life it's a blessing
oh i love you l'oreal
and we've got the crushed garlic too
that's going to go right in the marinade
all right last but not least it's root
beer time
how much let's add a can
and rice that would be about 12 ounces
all right look so now we got skirt stick
you can use flank
thinly slice whatever so we're just
gonna drop those right into the marinade
l'oreal let me ask you a question like
i prefer like a skirt or a flank
over a filet mignon but what is the
price difference am i
am i like is that a lucky preference
financially speaking drew that is really
a lucky preference
flank and square are usually around
13.99 a pound
but if you're talking about flame and
yawn especially if it's been dry aged
it's definitely gonna be upwards to
forty to sixty dollars a pound and
that's not even thinking about if you
weren't steakhouse
so yeah you're in luck there this is
definitely an affordable
that's really really helpful thank you i
love this skewered part of this
especially because you can like walk
around with a meat stick like it's fun
you know what i mean
can i see your mouth i want to sear
and sizzle i want to hear it can i do it
yes let's do it okay so you got your
cast iron it sounds like it's nice and
hot which is
exactly what we want there's a little
bit of smoky mist coming off of here
we're just going to add a touch of oil
not too much
maybe about a tablespoon and then what
you want to do is before we hear that
iconic sizzle look at these beautiful
scooters
let's just set those down and l'oreal
how much
on each side because that's always like
two minute rule
two minute rule i love that what i
really love about the
root beer and this recipe is that you
get the sugary caramelization on there
all right look at those those look so
good well
thank you um i'm really excited do you
mind if i
cheat and like taste one that's already
been cooked because i can't take it
no i want me to cheers
cheers laurie oh my god
oh my god you don't need a fork
oh my gosh you're driving your minivan
down the road with your kids eating this
oh my gosh okay it's been two minutes
i'm ready to
flip it and reverse it
same things
i'm sorry my butt has a mind of its own
right now
i'm just you know eating meat off a
stick and twerking
so that's good i
i can honestly say this is one of the
greatest
recipes this is this is a life changer
this is incredible oh my gosh
it's um thank you
i really wouldn't comment on it
would you call it a blessing piece
that's what called it
a bunch of me they show um
the thing that i really love about this
is how absolutely
tender the meat is and yet
it has this delicious sort of
caramelization
and a little bit of that grill on it
that i just associate with red meat
i i like a little bit of a sear in a
char
but the meat inside is like
butter it's just delicious the texture
is perfection
but the flavoring is so good and so
unique
and i'm guessing it must be that root
beer because it totally
doesn't taste like anything else and yet
it's fully addictive
thank you oh my gosh i like i'm in like
aromatherapy
realm over here well i thank you so much
because i am
definitely um i'm gonna make this with
my kids
and and and this is this is gonna be so
fun
it's so delicious this feels like it
would please
everybody by the way this is a
phenomenal super bowl
snack recipe i've got to say and
thank you l'oreal thank you drew okay
excellent well go to our website for the
full recipe anything i may have missed
l'oreal is going to give you all the
important tricks and tips
so just go to the drewberrymartian.com
and get your skewer
on and thank you l'oreal you really are